الوقت يطول في مباريات كاس العالم والجدل
يطول ايضا لكن هذا نوع من الجدل ليس جديدا
حول قريتي فيفا في مونديال البرازيل 2014
قررت فاستخدام تقنيه خط المرمى عين الصقر
لمعرفه تجاوز الكره بالكامل لخط المرمى
القرار اثار حفيظه اتحاد كره القدم
العالميه التي عبرت عن رفضها لما راته انه
يقتل متعه كره القدم في مونديال روسيا
2018 كانت الجبل الاكبر حول تقنيه الفار
التي اعلنت فيفا تطبيقها في مبارياته
القرار في ذلك الوقت اقلق القائمين على
كره القدم وكانت حجوتهم وقتها انه سيؤثر
على سير المباريات لكن اليوم اصبح بشهاده
نقاد اللعبه المحقق الاول لعداله كره
القدم
واليوم يبدو قرار لجنه حكام الفيفا بزياده
وقت البدل ضائع الاكثر حدثتا في عالم
الجدل والحجه تتعلق بفكره ان زياده الوقت
قد تخرج اللاعبين عن تركيزهم وتزيد من
احتماليه الاصابات